yesterday joe biden officially secured
270 electoral votes as all
50 states had their electors formally
cast their ballots
so yes this is the end except
it already was the end before and anyway
the trump cultists are still coming up
with new ideas
and again moving the goal posts which we
will get to but for those of you
who like me prefer to live in reality
you may recall that on november 3rd
the people voted in their states in a
state election which would determine
which electors would vote on december
14th which was yesterday
in the states where joe biden got more
votes on november 3rd
democratic electors cast electoral votes
for joe biden
in states where donald trump got more
votes on november 3rd
republican electors cast electoral votes
for donald trump
joe biden was expected to receive 306
electoral votes
based on the results from november 3rd
and indeed he did without a single
faithless elector based on the order in
which states voted california
shortly after 5 pm eastern cast its 55
electoral votes
for joe biden that officially put joe
biden over
270. so let's look at that for a moment
from the california state house
yesterday
i will now nice to announce the tally of
the vote for the office of president of
the united states
for joseph r biden of delaware a
democrat
eyes 55 nose zero
and with that joe biden now officially
the president-elect now remember
on no saturday november 7th i believe it
was
numerous media outlets started calling
joe biden the president-elect they
called the election for joe biden
that night joe biden addressing the
nation and people like donald trump and
others said the media does not get to
call
the election in any official sense and
the media doesn't decide who is
president-elect
now that was true then it was also true
in 2016 but in 2016 donald trump was
glad to accept the media's call
but now it is not the media it is the
electors
that have voted so is this it well
trump is say no because they still have
january 6th
january 6 what happens then on january 6
the house and senate hold a joint
session to count the electoral votes
and mike pence will oversee that as vice
president
al gore oversaw that in the year 2000
when he was defeated by george w
bush and mike pence will oversee it on
january 6th
as he has been defeated as well so the
new goal post
this is the point the new goal post is
that on january 6
republicans in the house and senate
during that joint session of congress to
count electoral votes
are going to have objections ready to go
it's likely that
when georgia when george's turn comes
to say we give our votes to joe biden or
pennsylvania
you will see a republican members of the
house and or senate stand and object
and mike pence will say for what reason
does the gentle lady from texas rise
today or whatever
and they will have some objection and
the goal
of that per the trumpist is
to prevent this from actually happening
on january 6th now it's going to happen
that this is what what's going to happen
on january 6th
you can already imagine the triggering
and donald trump absolutely losing his
mind yesterday as joe biden won the
electoral college
later in the evening joe biden
addressing the nation and trump just
tweeting and retweeting nonsense for
hours
posting debunked baseless election
conspiracy theory after theory
with apparently no understanding or
sense whatsoever that he's embarrassing
not only himself but the country
some example tweets i can't post them
all i like you too much to post all of
the to show
you all of them but some example tweets
from trump include
dominion voting machines are a disaster
all over the country
change the results of a landslide
election can't let this happen
thank you for the genius bravery and
patriotism of the judge
should get a medal no evidence
whatsoever of any of that
trump also tweeting many trump votes
were routed
to biden the highly respected michigan
judge released this epic report true all
over the country
this fake election can no longer stand
get moving republicans
big swing state win 75 million votes
that is also a completely baseless claim
which was flagged by twitter as such so
the good news is
we're getting closer guys it's it's not
that much longer and trump will be gone
and a major step yesterday with joe
biden becoming
a president-elect with 306
electoral votes cast in their respective
state houses
for president-elect joe biden and in the
midst of all of this
as if it wasn't an insane enough day
already attorney general william barr
has resigned let's discuss that next
if you are anything like me you probably
aren't thrilled with the idea of going
into
a doctor's office right now and
thankfully there is a practical
and affordable way to take control of
your health
and get personalized care from the
comfort of your home it's a service
called
steady md they're one of our sponsors
you take a quiz
you get matched with a licensed primary
care physician
who understands your health needs you
have a one-hour video call with your new
doctor
you establish a meaningful relationship
with them and after that
your doctor is available to you anytime
by text phone or video chat this is not
a random doctor on call
each doctor at steady md has a limited
number of patients so they actually have
time
to listen to you you get the personal
attention that you deserve
they can do almost everything an
in-person doctor can do
perform medical evaluations talk to you
about health concerns
send prescriptions to your home or local
pharmacy
and anything they can't do online
they'll quickly set you up with
an in-person provider to do things like
blood tests as an example
you don't need insurance it's only 99
bucks a month with
no other fees or co-pays there are so
many
practical advantages to using steady md
for primary care
and it's also so much more affordable
go to steadymd.com pacman to take the
free quiz see which doctor is right for
you i took their quiz they matched me
with
a doctor who specializes in my
particular health needs and situation
the doctor they gave me
is a really perfect fit for me and my
medical needs there's no risk no
commitment to get started
just click the link right underneath
this video